el otro que estaba checando los
comentarios que me dejan en los vídeos y
me encontré con una sugerencia
interesante de resolver problemas de
cálculo que realmente hayan aparecido en
un examen y que creen me encontré una
página con los problemas de respuesta
abierta de los exámenes de cálculo up
que es la clase de cálculo avanzada que
se da en eeuu en prepa vamos a hacer
algunos de estos el primero que vamos a
hacer es el problema 1 del examen de
2008 aunque no haya encontrado los de
opción múltiple no te preocupes vamos a
estar muy bien preparados para resolver
los de opción múltiple una vez que
podamos hacer los de respuesta abierta
pues usualmente los de respuesta abierta
son más difíciles sobre todo los últimos
años que tienen mucho chiste pero bueno
vamos a hacer esto voy a leer el
problema en voz alta porque me da un
poco de flojera copiarlo pero estoy aquí
es el diagrama que copie y pegue del pdf
de la página entonces ahí te va lo que
dice el problema en lo siguiente dice
sea r esté aquí es erre la región
acotada por la función igual a seno de
px déjame escribir eso entonces esta
gráfica de aquí arriba déjame marcarlo
así está esta gráfica de arriba
es que es igual a seno de px le voy a
escribir aquí ye igual a seno
debí
x
voy a ponerlo en paréntesis para que
veamos el seno de x
la gráfica de abajo es igual a x al cubo
menos 4x entonces esta de aquí es igual
a x al cubo menos 4x como supe que la de
arriba era seno de px pues fíjate que no
se ve como la de arriba verdad y fíjate
seno de pie cero seno de cero es cero y
seno de dos pies cero entonces la de
arriba tiene que ser seno de px pero
bueno de cualquier forma lo que nos
piden de encontrar es el área de la
región que está acotada por las dos
funciones es decir lo que queremos
determinar es el área de r esta de aquí
es la pregunta de calentamiento de lo
que se quieren asegurar es que sepamos a
ser integrales definidas va entonces
cómo le hacemos para hacer esto pues
vamos a plantear justo una integral
definida vamos a plantear la el área
entonces a es igual
pero si se ve bien verdad el área es
igual a la integral
de entonces cuáles son los límites de
integración hay que integrar desde x
igual a cero hasta x igual a 2
entonces hay que ponerle aquí 0 y aquí 2
y qué es lo que tenemos que integrar
pues vamos a tomar un valor de x y bueno
cuál va a ser cuál va a ser el área
verdad el área del rectángulo acuerda
que integrar es hacer el área es tomar
el área de muchos rectángulos y sumarlos
aquí estoy dibujando mi rectángulo va a
quedar algo así
no estoy pintando con azul
su ancho es de equis y cuál es su altura
su altura va a ser la diferencia entre
la función superior y la función
inferior
entonces esencialmente lo que queremos
hacer es tomar todas las áreas y
sumarlas entonces voy a poner otro color
así está más porque sí pero entonces la
altura va a ser la función inferior
menos la superior es decir seno seno de
pi x
aquí entre paréntesis menos la función
inferior la función de abajo es x al
cubo más 4x simplemente cambie los los
signos verdad como estaba restando
intercambiar los signos de ambos
términos todo esto de aquí hay que
multiplicarlo por el ancho de cada
rectángulo es decir x de x
baja entonces queremos sumar todos esos
desde x igual a cero hasta x igualados
esto de aquí debería ser muy directo
como lo hacemos para evaluarlo lo que
hay que hacer es que es encontrar la
primitiva de esta expresión evaluarla en
2 evaluarla en 0 y restar cuál es la
anti derivada de seno de px bueno qué
función cuando la derivamos nos queda
seno de x vamos a tomar la derivada de
coseno de x bueno no mejor la de coseno
de vieques la voy a escribir aquí abajo
vamos a ponerle coseno de pío x y eso de
ahí vamos a derivar lo con respecto a x
cuando la derivamos eso es igual a que
la derivada de lo de adentro usando la
regla de la cadena espn por la derivada
de lo de afuera la derivada de lo de
afuera es la deriva de kosher no es
menos seno entonces es menos seno
dp x
vamos a escribirle un poco más bonito
por acá - y por seno de px
sale entonces la derivada de coseno de
px casi es seno de pie quiso lo que
tiene por aquí una constante entonces
vamos a ver si podemos reescribir para
que se parezca más a la derivada de
coste no de px entonces fíjense el truco
va a ser el siguiente el truco va a ser
introducir un 1
ahí les va vamos a poner la integral de
0 a 2 y entonces lo que voy a hacer es
lo siguiente voy a poner voy a poner
fíjate voy a poner un -1 entre pi y voy
a multiplicar por menos pi
aquí no he hecho nada simplemente estoy
multiplicando por uno verdad arriba y
abajo puse lo mismo entonces nos queda
seno de iu x y luego tenemos que restar
x al cubo y sumar 4x todo eso de x
entonces ahora que podemos hacer pues ya
sabemos que la primitiva de esta
expresión es coseno de px esto es una
constante entonces simplemente puede
salir de la integral entonces cuál es la
anti derivada de toda la expresión pues
la anti derivada es la anticipada de
esto que es coseno de pie que voy a
ponerlo por aquí menos 1 entre p coseno
de pío x recuerda esta constante
simplemente la saqué del integral esto
de aquí corresponde a esta anti derivada
y las de acá son más fáciles porque son
polinomiales es menos la anti derivada
de x al cubo que es x a la cuarta
dividido entre 4 y hay que sumar hay que
sumar la anti derivada de 4x es 4x
cuadrada entre 2 que podemos simplificar
como 2x cuadrada
y eso de ahí tenemos que evaluarlo con
límite superior 2 y elemento inferior 0
vamos a hacer eso entonces esto es igual
a coseno de 2
vamos a poner el menos aquí / / p menos
2 a la cuarta cuanto estos a la cuarta 2
al cubo es 8 y por otro 2 nos queda 16 y
16 dividido entre 4 es 4
entonces nos queda menos 4 y hay que
sumar 2 x cuadrado es decir 2 por 2 al
cuadrado o sea 8
esto de aquí es este término evaluado en
2 ahora lo que hay que restar es el
término evaluado en 0 entonces aquí nos
quedaría coseno de bueno nos quedarían
menos coseno de 0 / / pi
/ p
y luego hay que restar 0 a la cuarta
entre 4 0 2 por 0 que 0 entonces ya lo
dejamos así entonces que obtenemos cuál
es el valor de coseno de dos picos en
los dedos pies lo mismo que cose no de
cero y eso es igual a uno entonces josé
no de dos bien trevi a ver nos quedaría
menos uno entre pi no hay que restar
cuatro hay que sumar el ocho
aquí hay un menos menos por menos da más
los podemos poner como más coseno de
cero otra vez es 1 entonces nos queda
más uno entre pi y fíjate este se
cancela con este vamos a tachar los lo
cancelamos por aquí lo cancelamos por
acá y lo único que nos queda es menos 4
más 8 que es igual a 4 listo ya quedó
esa de ahí fue la parte a del problema 1
de 2008 de este examen que les conté
espero hacer algunos vídeos más con los
otros inciso si de hecho hacer algunos
de estos ejemplos diario uno o dos más o
menos nos vemos en los siguientes vídeos